la séance est ouverte l'ordre du jour
appelle les questions au Gouvernement la
première va être posée par Monsieur loï
carvrand pour le groupe
horizon merci merci madame la Présidente
ma question s'adresse à madame la
ministre de l'Éducation nationale et j'y
associe mon collègue député d'Ur etloire
Luc lamirot madame la ministre dans le
Cher mais aussi dans de nombreux autres
territoires ruraux partout en France les
directeurs académiques s'apprêtent à
fermer des classes rurales par dizaines
dans des proportions
inédites nous regrettons que trop
souvent en lieu et place de la
concertation nécessaire sur l'avenir de
nos écoles en ruralité il n'y ait que le
déploiement d'un processus de
concentration des moyens dans les plus
grandes
communes cette concentration sans
concertation elle se fait au détriment
de la cohérence avec les politiques
publiques en faveur de la ruralité
portée par les autres acteurs de l'État
dans le Cher l'inspection académique
veut fermer là où les élus ont investi
dans dans la rénovation de leurs écoles
là où l'on ouvre avec le ministère de
l'intérieur des gendarmeries là où l'on
crée des accueils périscolaires là où
sont scolariser les enfants de nos
agriculteurs comment croire que c'est en
fermant des classes que l' combattra la
perte démographique de beaucoup de nos
communes rurale il est urgent de changer
la logique dans l'approche de la
fermeture des classes dans les
territoires où est l'égalité quand le
même chiffre de 15 élèves et l'objectif
à atteindre dans les écoles de banlieu
et l'arrêt de mort de nos classes en
ruralité ça fait des années que nous
demandons à revoir la carte de
l'éducation prioritaire pour qu'elle
puisse prendre enfin en compte la
ruralité et ses spécificités il nous
faut faire une pause dans le vaste
transfert de moyens de nos campagnes
vers les villes et se donner la
possibilité de réfléchir sereinement au
futur de nos écoles en
ruralité pour moi qui suis un enfant de
la campagne un élu de la ruralité qui
est mes enfants dans l'école publique de
mon village
ces classes ne sont pas des lignes dans
un tableur Excel c'est la France de
demain c'est une question d'aménagement
du territoire c'est la vie de nos
enfants madame la ministre quel avenir
souhaitez-vous dessiner pour nos écoles
rurales merci beaucoup mon chers
collègues la parole est à Madame Amélie
oua casterra ministre de l'Éducation
Nationale de la Jeunesse des sports des
Jeux Olympiques et paralympies madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés monsieur le député votre
question est cruciale car elle aborde le
double sujet de l'égalité des chances et
de l'équité entre les territoires
l'école rurale elle se caractérise par
une bonne performance scolaire des
élèves mais leur ambition scolaire et
d'orientation après le collège peut
paraître parfois moins soutenu qu'en
milieu urbain et périurbain on a
accéléré d'ors et déjà sur le sujet dans
le cadre du Plan France ruralité avec
trois décisions fortes qui ont été
prises la première donner une meilleure
visibilité sur trois 3 ans aux
évolutions de la carte scolaire en
prenant bien en compte tous les secteurs
ruraux avec le bon niveau de maillage et
de lecture deuxièmement installer dans
tous les départements une instance de
dialogue et de concertation qui est
coprécisé par le préfet et le daen et
qui réunit des représentants des
associations des maires ruraux des
maires et le Conseil départemental
pourquoi pour partager les informations
et conduire les analyses collégiales
trème décision soutenir les territoires
éducatifs ruraux qui permettent de
renforcer la prise en charge pédagogique
et éducative de nos enfants concernant
les décisions qui doivent être prises
dans les prochains jours au sujet de la
carte scolaire si dans certains
départements des concertations
complémentairire s'avèrent nécessaire je
m'y engage elles seront menées sous
l'autorité des daenes et des préfets
notre école elle doit être la même pour
tous et elle a évidemment un avenir tout
particulier dans nos ruralités elle a
une place essentielle à y jouer et je
m'y engage devant vous je ferai de la
place de l'école dans nos ruralité l'une
de mes priorités au sein de ce ministère
je vous
remercie merci beaucoup madame la
ministre la parole pour le rassemblement
national est à Madame Laurence Robert
Deo merci Madame la présid Madame le
Ministre chers cègues en février 2023 le
gouvernement utilise nm 493 pour faire
passer l'impopulaire réforme des
retraites ce rabotage sur les droits
sociaux se justifie par une promesse
remettre les comptes sociaux à
l'équilibre aujourd'hui le gouvernement
souhaite encore réaliser des économies
sur le dos des Français le reste à
charge médicale va doubler dès mars les
Français devront payer 1 € par boîte de
médicament 2 € pour les consultations
des médecins et les analyses médicales 4
€ pour les transports sanitaires le
ministre de l'Économie nous explique que
ces montants n'avaient pas été Aug
depuis leur création félicitations ce
gouvernement sera donc le premier à le
faire le gouvernement poursuit dans sa
politique de paupérisation des Français
qui souffr déjà des déserts médicaux de
la hausse des coûts des complémentaires
santé en outre nous faisons face à une
pénurie de médicaments les signalements
de rupture de stock sont en hausse de
128 % par rapport à 2021 nous vous
alertons depuis des années qu'avez-vous
fait depuis 2022 les prélèvements
obligatoires n'ont jamais été aussi
élevés et pourtant les Français ont de
moins en moins de 3 le Premier ministre
a indiqué hier que la solidarité
nationale devra s'exercer pour nos
classes moyennes après 7 ans de
gouverance macroniste il serait temps de
s'en rendre compte notre système de
sécurité sociale ne protège plus nos
compatriotes et notre modèle de
solidarité nationale assurée par la
redistribution ne profite plus aux
Français selon l'INC la différence du
poids des aides sociales dans le revenu
des familles mérite l'application le
plus rapidement possible du principe de
priorité nationale à quelques mois des
élections européennes le Premier
ministre a multiplié les appels du pied
envers les classes moyennes or ce sont
elles qui vont subir cette hausse de
plein fou madame la ministre le
gouvernement va-t-il cesser ces
mensonges et assumer clairement qu'il
continuera de ponctionner les Français
des classes moyennes je vous remercie je
vous remercie la parole est à Madame
Catherine vutin ministre du Travail de
la santé et des
solidarités merci madame la Présidente
mesdames et messieurs les députés madame
la députée madame la députée je crois
qu'il est important qu'on se dise les
choses tout à fait clairement le modèle
social français est un modèle unique il
est tellement unique qu'il n'a été copié
nulle part ailleurs dans le monde et sa
spécificité c'est qu'il fait peser son
poids sur nos concitoyens qui
travaillent et c'est clairement un sujet
le Premier ministre l'a rappelé hier
parce que ce poids du modèle social a
des conséquences très concrètes sur la
vie de nos concitoyens la santé madame
la députée est dans notre pays l'une des
meilleures du monde et je crois que
c'est le moment de redire tout
l'engagement des professionnels de santé
dans notre pays nous sommes excellents
en matière curative nous le sommes moins
en matière préventive et cela m'amène à
vous dire un mot sur la responsabilité
qui est celle de chacune et chacun
d'entre nous car non madame la santé
n'est pas gratuite la gratuité ça
n'existe pas il y a toujours quelqu'un
qui P et aujourd'hui quand effectivement
on a des besoins de santé qu'on a un
premier objectif qui est la prévention
pour garder son capital c'est la
première chose que chacun d'entre nous
peut faire et qui ne coûte rien le
deuxième élément c'est comment nous
pouvons effectivement participer à
l'effort participer à l'effort à un
moment où les uns et les autres font des
choix mettre 1 € sur sa boîte de
médicament c'est aussi prendre
conscience de la valeur de ce que ce
médicament il faut avoir le courage de
le dire à nos concitoyens ce n'est pas
de la démagogie c'est la réalité de la
responsabilité c'est ce que nous allons
faire et c'est le sens du message que
nous devons partager avec les Français
merci beaucoup madame la ministre madame
la
députée madame la ministre la me est
gratuite je vous merci la parole pour le
groupe Gauche démocrate et républicaine
est à Monsieur
jean-marcier
madame la présidente madame la ministre
de l'Éducation nationale chers collègues
depuis des mois l'éducation nationale
vit à travers une avalangeche de
déclarations et d'annonces
ministérielles nous assistons à un choc
des paroles qui malgré les leurs fracas
médiatique sont surtout déconnectés des
véritables enjeux de notre école
publique dans ce contexte de
communication superficiel aucune
proposition ne vient répondre aux
attentes et aux besoins des élèves et
des enf enseignant sous le couvert du
renforcement c'est surtout un retour en
arrière où l'État n'assure pas à chaque
élève la possibilité d'avoir le même
bagage à la fin de sa
scolarité ces annonces dépourvu de toute
promesse de moyens supplémentair vont
creuser davantage les inégalités
sociales il est temps de parler
clairement les enseignants qui
manifesteront demain attendre des
réponses ni la généralisation des
uniformes à
ni la mise en place de classes de niveau
gommeront les inégalités sociales
l'inclusion ne doit pas rester un simple
slogan les enseignants ont besoin de
salair plus élevés la carte scolaire
doit être réformée pour garantir une
égalité d'accès à l'éducation dans nos
villes nos quartiers et nos
campagnes partout en France la
dégradation de notre école continue dans
mon département le pas decalais forcez
de constater que la future carte
scolaire prévoit la suppression de 89
postes pourtant pourtant chaque jour
c'est 96 classe qui se retrouve sans
professeur faute de remplacement rien
que sur ma commune la ville d'Avion C
postes seront supprimés pour 19 enfants
en moins je sais madame la ministre que
les remplacements sont un sujet qui vous
préoccupe alors quand deviendra
deviendrontil une priorité absolue
madame la ministre quand gverement quand
le gouvernement va-t-il renouer avec
l'école de sa république avec l'école de
l'égalité je vous remercie la parole est
à Madame Amélie oua Castera ministre de
l'Éducation Nationale de la Jeunesse des
Sports Monsieur le Député Tellier merci
pour votre question l'égalité des
chances l'attractivité du métier
d'enseignant mais plus largement comme
l'a montré le Premier ministre hier soir
la focalisation sur l'ensemble des
métiers du service public de
l'enseignement sont absolument au cœur
de notre politique éducative au cœur de
notre ambition pour l'école toutes les
écoles de la République je voudrais
souligner que la carte scolaire est le
résultat d'un travail continu entre des
services académiques et départementaux
en lien étroit avec les collectivités
locales et les ajustements de cette
carte scolaire qui sont parfois exigés
par l'impact des politiques publiques ou
l'évolution de la démographie doivent se
faire en concertation étroite avec les
élus et j'y vais
nellement sur le sujet des remplacements
qui est en effet une problématique
décisive nous avons décidé de la traiter
prioritairement de premières mesures ont
été impulsées par Gabriel Atal pour nous
permettre d'améliorer notre organisation
de faire aussi recours aux heures
supplémentaires et de créer de nouvelles
incitations pour que les enseignants
puissent davantage remplacer leurs
collègues dans le cadre du pacte que
nous évaluerons sur tous ces sujets vous
connaissez notre engagement notre envie
de faire réussir tous les élèves de
faire réussir toutes les écoles pour
remettre en marche l'ascenseur scolaire
je vous
remercie je vous remercie madame la
ministre la parole est à madame Cécile
intermer pour le groupe socialiste merci
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse au ministre de l'Économie
l'indice de perception de la corruption
publiée hier par Transparency
internationale n'est pas bon il situe
notre pays à la 25e place très loin
derrière le Danemark la Finlande
l'Allemagne selon cet indice qui est
connu et bien partagé dans le monde nous
payons le manque d'exemplarité du
pouvoir exécutif un système judiciaire
fragile est le manque de moyens
consacrés à la délinquence économique et
financière sur le premier point
convenons que les derniers signaux
envoyés sont mauvais et aggravés par la
nomination de ministres qui n'emporte
pas tous la confiance et le silence sur
la proposition réitérée de
l'Observatoire de l'éthique publique de
nommer un déontologue au gouvernement
comme partout ailleurs sur le dernier
point c'est le développement massif du
narcotrafic dans l'économie qui nous
préoccupe un développement qui trouve
nous le savons tous son terreau dans une
corruption sans limite hier lors de la
déclaration de politique générale le
Premier ministre a rappelé que la France
n'est pas n'importe quel pays qu'elle
dispose d'un héritage moral remarquable
et affirmeré de voir identifier tous les
ressorts sur lesquels on peut agir
gouverner certes n'est pas facile mais
l'engagement dans une politique publique
de lutte contre la corruption doit être
totale elle doit nous rassembler et être
débattu ici en séance publique alors
Monsieur le Ministre de l'économie sur
quel ressort le Gouvernement entend-il
agir pour combattre cette corruption qui
mine la démocratie et ruine la confiance
des Français êtes-vous partant pour
engager collectivement ce combat et en
débattre ici en séance
publique je vous remercie merci la
parole est à Monsieur Bruno Le Maire
ministre de l'économie et des finances
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
nous sommes évidemment ouverts à avoir
un débat sur ce sujet je partage
totalement votre préoccupation et notre
ambition avec le Premier ministre le
président de la République l'ensemble de
la majorité de lutter avec encore plus
de fermeté contre la corruption le
classement que vous mentionnez nous fait
gagner une place c'est pas beaucoup mais
au moins ça va dans la bonne direction
si nous voulons continuer à progresser
et une fois encore je partage totalement
votre ambition un pays comme la France
le pays des droits de l'homme de la
République doit être exemplaire en
matière de lutte contre la corruption du
trafic d'influence des conflits
d'intérêts dans le secteur public comme
dans le secteur privé nous avons des
instruments qui sont efficaces pour le
public la Haute autorité pour la
transparence de la vie publique nous
avons l'agence de lutte antiorruption
qui a été créée il y a quelques années
qui est extrêmement efficace et qui fait
un bon travail et nous voulons avec le
garde des saau aller plus loin dans les
mois qui viennent puisque le président
de la République et le Premier ministre
nous ont demandé de travailler à un
nouveau plan contre la corruption sur
lequel nous sommes prêts à travailler
avec l'ensemble des parlementaires qui
sont présents je rappelle au passage le
ministre de la Justice le sait bien que
nous avons augmenté de 60 % les moyens
de la justice depuis 2017 don nous avons
fait le maximum pour nous donner les
moyens de lutter contre la corruption et
être exemplaire dans ce domaine enfin un
tout dernier mot dans la référence que
vous faites à ce rapport je rappelle
juste un point qui me paraît très
important la lutte contre la corruption
ne doit pas se faire au détriment de la
présomption d'innocence qui est un
principe cardinal de notre justice et de
notre droit je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre madame la députée bon j'entends
vos propos rassurant monsieur le
ministre et je vous remercie mais je
pense quand même que la bonne direction
serait de poser le débat de la Cour de
Justice de la République comme l'avait
annonc le président de la République il
serait aussi de poser le débat sur le
renouvellement d'anticorps qui d'après
même les magistrats est un outil utile à
la justice et à la lutte contre la
corruption je vous
remercie la parole est à Madame Laurence
céel Grillère pour le groupe
[Applaudissements]
Renaissance merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Premier Ministre il doit y
avoir une exception agricole fr
il faut mettre l'agriculture au-dessus
de tout ces mots que vous avez prononcé
les agriculteurs les attendaient
investis depuis plus de 30 ans sur les
questions agricoles de la qualité de
l'eau des sols et des produits
alimentaires j'ai vu entendu et
accompagner nos agriculteurs face aux
impasse technique et sanitaire face à la
prédation la guerre des prix la
paperasserie l'agribaching toujours à la
recherche de solutions contrairement à
ceux qui veulent interdire ou détruire
les réserves d'eau ceux qui remettent en
cause l'élevage ceux qui va l'interdire
sans alternative des molécules
autorisées partout dans le monde ceux
qui prétendent que l'on peut faire sans
l'Europe et qui vont pour la première
fois à la rencontre des agriculteurs
contrairement à ces opportunistes la
majorité a fait le choix d'accompagner
nos
agriculteurs en réponse à leur demande
vous avez pris une décision ferme sur le
GNR sans inspecteur supplémentair de la
DGCCRF ont commencé leur contrôle dans
le cadre d'galim toutes les amendes
infligé à
à la grande distribution seront
réutilisé pour soutenir les
agriculteurs 250 millions d'euros ont
été débloqués pour trouver des
alternativ au pesticides un fond
d'urgence est déployé pour nos vignerons
un grand nombre de mesures qui
répondront au moins pour parti à la
crise agricole mais l'agriculture
française est multiple loin des grandes
terres cultivées ou des Grandes Terres
d'élevage l'Ardèche mon département se
caractérise par la diversité de ses
productions avec des cerises des
châignes des plantes aromatiques de la
volaille des élevages caprins des
exploitations de petite taille très
diversifié avec pour chacune des
productions des difficultés techniques
des impasses voire des importations à
bas cout alors Monsieur le Premier
Ministre ma question est la suivante
face à la diversité de notre agriculture
comment comptez-vous agir pour permettre
à chacun de nos agriculteurs de vivre de
son métier tout en retrouvant notre
souveraineté alimentaire et en
accélérant notre transition merci
beaucoup merci beaucoup la parole est à
Madame Prisc evau porte-parole du
gouvernement et ministre en charge de du
renouveau
démocratique merci madame la présidente
madame la députée merci pour cette
question qui me permet en mon nom mais
surtout au nom du premier ministre de
saluer votre travail à vous en tant que
député mais ass à l'ensemble de vos
collègues parce que oui vous n'avez pas
attendu que les caméras viennent sur les
points de blocage pour aller à la
rencontre des agriculteurs des
viticulteurs je peux vous citer vous je
pourrais citer le député casbarian je
pourrais citer la députée Marsau je
pourrais citer la députée clapo ainsi de
suite vous avez toujours été au contact
et grâce à ce contact grâce à ces
échanges dès 2017 vous avez pu faire
avancer un certain nombre de lois qui
étaient attendu de longu dates la loi
égalime 1 la loi égalime 2 la loi é
galime 3 mais également l'assurance au
récolte parce que si certains se lamente
sur les alléas climatiques vous y avez
fait face pour faire voter la réforme
d'assurance récolte donc encore une fois
merci nous allons continuer sur la base
du travail entamé par le Premier
ministre lui-même dès la semaine
dernière des premières annonces ont été
faites sur le GNR comme vous venez de le
rappeler mais aussi des mesures très
rapides sur les normes nous continuons
dès la semaine dès cette semaine
notamment à Bruxelles où est en ce
moment le ministre de l'Agriculture et
demain le président de la République
sera lui aussi à la manœuvre pour qu'on
continuer à défendre cette exception
agricole dont nous sommes si fiers merci
merci beaucoup madame la
ministre la parole est à Madame Aurélie
trouv pour le groupe la France
insoumise madame la Présidente chers
collègues monsieur le ministre de
l'Économie depuis une semaine c'est le
festival des promesses creuses pour
répondre à la colère des agriculteurs il
vous demande de les protéger des
importations à pris cassé mais depuis 25
ans l'Europe avec la France multiplie
les accords de libre échange avec un but
gagner des marchés pour les grands
groupes de l'industrie et des services
en décimant l'agriculture française
depuis 7 ans le président Macron finit
de sacrifier les agriculteurs il a
ratifié un accord avec le Japon
Singapour le Vietnam le Chili
Nouvelle-Zélande et il soutient les
accords avec le mercosour l'Australie
l'Inde l'Indonésie la Thaïlande et
pendant que vous y êtes vous allez
peut-être nous ressortir le tafta alors
vous nous dites pas inquiétude j'engage
un bras de fer avec Bruxelles en
endormant les éleveurs français avec des
closes miroirs ça ne vous dérange donc
pas d'avoir des dizaines de milliers de
tonnes de viande importé en plus
d'Australie ou du Brésil qui viennent
d'élevage de dizaines de milliers de
bêtes où le coût du foncier est presque
nul qui passe par des abattoirs géants
où le SMIC n'existe pas close miroir ou
pas c'est une concurrence insoutenable
pour les éleveurs que vous imposez c'est
vrai aussi pour la pêche les fruits les
légumes comment osez-vous faire croire
que vous protégez l'exception agricole
française ça fait des semaines que le
président Macron nous répète que la
France a mis fin aux négociations avec
le mercosour c'est faux le
vice-président de la commission européen
dombrovski le rappelle hier les
négociations se se poursuivent comme
prévu monsieur le ministre stop notre
agriculture se meurt de votre folie
dérégulatrice une autre agriculture est
possible à condition de la protéger des
multinationales et de la concurrence
internationale vous devez convoquer un
conseil européen retirer le mandat de la
France des négociations de tous les
accords de libre échange en cours à
commencé par le mercosour oui ou non le
ferez-vous je vous remercie ma cher
collègue la parole est à Monsieur bruneo
le Maire ministre de l'économie et des
financesame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame les député
trouvé tout d'un coup la France
insoumise découv qu'il y a des paysans
en
France après avoir proposé des
augmentations de taxes des augmentations
d'impôts des durcissements de règles et
des durcissements de normes vous venez
au soutien des paysans et des
agriculteurs il n'est jamais trop tard
pour bien faire s'agissant du Mercosur
madame trouvé je vous rappelle qu'il n'y
a qu'un seul État en Europe par la voix
du président de la République qui
s'oppose à la signature en l'état de
l'accord
c'est la France et c'est le président de
la
République nous avons réussi à bloquer
ces négociations parce que nous estimons
que cet accord en l'état est injuste
qu'il mettrait nos éleveurs dans une
difficulté insoutenable et qui n'est pas
question de laisser rentrer sur le sol
européen des dizaines de milliers de
tonnes de bétail qui ne respectent pas
les mêmes normes et les mêmes règles que
celle que nous imposons à nos éleveurs
et à nos producteurs enfin je rappelle
madame trou gr au président de la
République et la négociation qu'il a
mené avec le gouvernement chinois que
nous pouvons exporter des ports de
Bretagne et que le kilo de port de
Bretagne son prix a augmenté parce que
nous pouvons l'exporter vers la Chine je
rappelle que notre balance commerciale a
viticulture augmente parce que nous
pouvons exporter plus de vin vers le
Japon et je rappelle que nos producteurs
de lait sont bien contents de pouvoir
exporter 50 % de fromage de plus vers le
Canada parce que nous avons signé un
accord de libre échange avec le Canada
ne tuez pas l'agriculture française avec
vos mauvaises idées madame la
députée je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre la parole est à présent pour le
groupe écologiste à Madame Sabrina
CEBA madame la ministre des Sports un
enfant sur 7 est victime de violence
dans le sport un bénévole sur de au
contact de nos enfants ne fait l'objet
d'aucun contrôle de ses antécédents
judiciaires et la plateforme de
signalement des violences sexistes et
sexuelles de votre ministère méconnu
tous ces dysfonctionnements vous les
avez reconnus ils sont de votre
responsabilité pourtant votre priorité
depuis 10 jours et encore hier soir lors
des vœux du comité olympique a été
d'attaquer le travail du Parlement et de
notre commission et cela au mépris total
de la séparation des pouvoirs ce rapport
a pourtant été largement salué par les
victimes pour lesquelles vous n'avez eu
aucun mot ce rapport vous dérange car il
vient bousculer votre caste de
privilégié il démontre que la France n'a
pas totalement tourné le dos à une
logique aristocratique d' caparement du
pouvoir digne des descriptions de Balzac
qui écrivait en parlant du faubourg
Saint-Germain quartier que vous
connaissiez bien le travail se couche
lorsque l'aristocratie son jadiné ce
système vous permet de maintenir
quelques familles au pouvoir des clans
dirons-nous dign d'une période largement
dépassé cet entre soi consanguin vous a
fait passer sans aucune réserve et sans
la moindre procédure de recrutement
d'une société privée à une grande
fédération sportive avec à la clé un
salaire jugé anormal par l'Inspection
Générale placée sous V notre propre
autorité dire aujourd'hui que l'on perd
de l'argent en étant ministre dire que
500000 € de salaire en étant dirigeante
et mérité doit hulcérer les agriculteurs
qui bloquent nos routes en ce moment
pour espérer toucher ne serait-ce qu'un
SMIC et qui se heurte à la surdité du
gouvernement dans votre monde les
grandes familles se croisent se
regroupent et s'associent vous y croisez
notamment le chemin de Marc ladr de la
chargère dont on connaît depuis
l'affaire Fillon les talents en
recrutement et en gestion de carrière
tout cela incarne bien la transformation
du président de la République entre sa
première élection et la fin de son
second sacre il nous avait promis le
Nouveau Monde il nous lgra finalement
l'Ancien Régime madame la ministre ma
question est simple plus que dans votre
monde il est normal de toucher 500000 €
pour les heures de travail enfourné
comme vous le dites quelle considération
méritent les agriculteurs les
professeurs et les bénévoles sur les
terrains je vous remercie la parole est
à Madame Amélie oua Castera ministre de
l'éducation nationale de la jeunesse et
des
sportsame député madame la députée
Sabrina s donc vous recommencez à
m'attaquer à m'attaquer personnellement
alors je vais d'abord vous remercier
pour votre question qui est en effet
l'occasion pour moi de saluer à la fois
la présidente bamie pour son effort
constant d'objectivation des travaux de
la commission d'enquête et de remercier
de saluer chacun des parlementaires qui
ont contribué à la bonne marche de ces
travaux avec un objectif faire
progresser le sport c'est le mien aussi
et je vous en
remercie simplement voilà ce travail
parlementaire de qualité vous l'avez
dévoyé vous l'avez dévoyé dans votre
rapport dans l'atterrissage dans votre
rapport où vous en êtes servi pour
diviser pour attaquer pour stigmatiser
sur les plateaux télé dans les réseaux
sociaux ou par des formules à
l'emporte-pèces et ça vous l'avez fait
par opportunisme pour surfer sur la
vague médiatique des crises des
fédérations que nous avons géré que nous
avons solutionner arrêtez de donner des
leçons madame SBI où étiez-vous où
étiez-vous depuis 2020 quand le
gouvernement a pris à bras le corp comme
aucun avant lui le sujet de la lutte
contre les violences sexuelles et
sexises dans le sport où étiez-vous
madame la députée en novembre dernier
lorsqu'on a discuté ici même les crédits
pour le sport pour 2024 avec des moyens
inédits que nous avons réussi à
décrocher pour la lutte contre les
violences vous étiez absente madame la
députée vous étiez absente de ces débats
et moi j'ai poussé pour les signalements
la progression du contrôle
dehonorabilité j'ai été constamment
comme je continuerai à l'êre au côté des
victimes de violence à caractère sexiste
ou sexuel madame la députée je suis Fiè
du travail que nous avons entrepris et
lucide sur ce qui reste à accomplir pour
améliorer notre modèle sportif ce combat
pour l'éthique l'intégrité dans le sport
il mérite mieux que de veines attaques
politiciennes ce combat pour le sport
nous devons le mener et le mener tous
ensemble merci beaucoup madame la
ministre la parole est à Madame Louise
Morel pour le groupe
démocrate merci madame la Présidente ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de la transition écologique et
de la cohésion des territoires et
j'associe à cette question Monsieur
Laurent Croisier député du Doux monsieur
le ministre ma question concerne ma
prime rénove l'Agence nationale de
l'habitat a annoncé au début du mois de
décembre qu'elle prévoit une baisse de
30 % des forfaits ma prime renove pour
l'installation d'équipement de chauffage
fonctionnant au bois la réduction sera
effective dans quelques semaines à peine
le 1er avril
2024 l'annonce est brutale elle est sans
concertation avec une filière qui
pourtant se structure depuis des années
pour accompagner la transition
énergétique de nos bâtiments soyons
clair cette décision marquera un coup
d'arrêt pour les remplacements des
chaudières au fuel par des chaudières
biomasse plus performante et neutre en
carbone et cela va également à
l'encontre des objectifs
environnementaux et de
réindustrialisation de notre pays je
dois également préciser que l'inquiétude
est vive pour la pérennité des 450000
emplois directs et indirects de cette
filière filière qui je le rappelle a été
mise à Rud d'épreuve l'an dernier lors
de la crise des granulé de bois
rappelons-nous les peletiss ont vu leur
prix bondir de manière exponentielle
entraînant perte de confiance et
effondrement des ventes desqu équipement
de chauffage au bois en 2023 sur 1 an le
volume des ventes a diminué de 72 %. à
l'heure où nous devons plus que jamais
être vigilant sur notre consommation
d'énergie ces annonces semblent en
décalage elles inquiètent nos
concitoyens en particulier ceux qui
vivent dans les régions les plus froides
de notre pays aussi Monsieur le Ministre
pouvez-vous nous faire part de
l'intention du gouvernement à l'égard de
cette filière qui participe à sa mesure
à renforcer l'indépendance énergétique
de la France et plus globalement dans
les discussions à venir sur l'énergie
quelles actions entendez-vous prendre
sur la place des granulés de bois dans
notre mix énergétique afin de se
prémunir face à une nouvelle crise à
l'avenir je vous remercie je vous
remercie la parole est à Monsieur
christop Béchu ministre de la transition
écologique et de la cohésion des
territoires madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés madame
la députée Louise Morel maprenov ça a
été une multiplication par 10 d'une
nombre de rénovation depuis 2017 par
rapport au quinquena précédent une
partie de ceux qui hier ont sont montés
à cette tribune donn des leçons au
moment de la suite de la discussion de
politique générale pour expliquer que
sur le plan écologique nous n'avons rien
fait ils nous ont laissé une situation
il y avait 700 rénovation par an ce
chiffre a été multiplié par 10 la vérité
nous oblige à regarder ce que sont nos
marges de progression et de manœuvre la
marge de progression c'est le nombre de
rénovations performantes et c'est le
fait d'être certain dans les choix en
particulier de vecteurs que nous aidons
les Français à faire les bons choix avec
une priorité sortir du fossile il arrive
qu'autour des questions du bois énergie
il y a des débats certains considérant
que si on pousse trop une filière de
chauffage au bois ça pourrait desservir
ce que nous avons à faire par ailleurs
au titre de la biomasse et vous évoquez
des émotions légitimes qui remontent sur
plusieurs territoires on a augmenté les
moyens plus 100 milillard 6 pour l'année
en cours on a modifié les règles avec un
pilier performance et avec un pilier
efficacité mais ce dispos positif
n'échappe pas une partie des critiques
posées par le Premier ministre hier sur
la nécessité de déburaucratiser et de
simplifier le dispositif aussi le 15
février prochain dans quelques jours je
réunirai les artisans pour avec eux
regarder dans le détail ce que sont ces
irritants qui parfois sont extrêmement
légitimes on a des billets de calcul sur
les petites surfaces de DPE il faut pas
jeter la totalité mais il faut regarder
comment on corrige le dispositif il faut
qu'on fasse attention à ne pas aller
trop loin en une forme de neutralité
d'humilité à l'échelle de l'État et en
mesurant que avoir une vision unique
partout en France du type de vecteur à
utiliser ne correspond pas aux réalités
du territoire et on doit être capable de
regarder cette question de production
d'énergie de manière transversale je le
fais depuis quelques jours avec joie
avec Bruno leemire qui a en charge la
production de l'énergie et pour ma
partie au titre de l'efficacité de la
sobriété nous allons faire en sorte
d'avancer ensemble pour accélérer la
planification écologique en tenant
compte de ce qui nous remte du terrain
je vousci merci Monsieur le
Ministre la parole est à Monsieur Paul
mollac pour le groupe
Liot merci Madame la président ma
question s'adresse au ministre de
l'Agriculture je me suis rendu lundi sur
plusieurs barrages à la rencontre des
agriculteurs du morbillan pour les
entendre si les annonces concernant la
suppression de la hausse de la taxe du
gazol non routier et le financement des
Maek pour lequel je vous avais interrogé
en novembre dernier ont été bien
accueillies elles ont été jugées
insuffisantes et la mobilisation perdure
je me fais ici le relais de leur
revendication deux points essentiels la
surréglementation et les négociations du
Mercosur la surréglementation le choix
de sanctuiriser les prairies avec
impossibilité de les retourner après 5
ans d'existence pose problème ainsi que
les nouvelles normes européennes qui
classent les élevages comme usine on ne
me fera pas croire qu'un poulayer de
1500 m car est une usine dans les années
80 j'en avais déjà 1800
m² là ce n'est pas pas possible le
Mercosur que nous disent les
agriculteurs ils nous disent vous nous
demandez de mettre en place de nouvelles
normes on peut le
comprendre mais dans ce cas ne nous
mettez pas en concurrence avec des
produits qui ne sont pas faits avec les
mêmes normes sociales et
environnementales et donc ma question
est simple aurez-vous une majorité dans
demain pour que le mercosour soit remis
en cause au moins sur les accords
agricoles
je vous remercie monsieur le député la
parole est à Monsieur Christophe Béchu
ministre de la transition écologique et
de la cohésion des
territoires merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Député maollac merci
pour merci pour votre question en
l'absence du ministre de l'Agriculture
je réponds parce qu'on est à cheval sur
des sujets dans lequel parfois au nom de
l'écologie on finit par susciter une
forme d'énervement ou d'excitation une
partie les agriculteurs et dont il faut
le dire elles sont parfois légitimes
elles le sont de deux pour deux raisons
d'abord si on a des règles qui
s'appuient sur une exigence écologique
comment expliquer à nos concitoyens que
ce qui serait bon pour la planète
nécessite de fixer des règles en France
mais qui ne s'appliquerait pas dans
d'autres endroits du monde derrière
Mercosur c'est la question tout
simplement de la du piégeage de carbone
on peut pas à la fois regretter la
déforestation et de l'autre laisser des
accords de libre échange accentuer cette
déforestation en laissant entrer des
produits qui avec un dumping social et
environnemental aggrave le problème
écologique vous évoquez ensuite une
directive compliquée qui est la
directive IED compliquée en particulier
pour tout l'ouest de la France qui
aboutirait si elle été adoptée tel quel
parce que on classe comme ICPE une
partie de ce qui notamment travaille sur
la viande blanche et avec là aussi deux
objections la première c'est de
comprendre qu'il a la nécessité d'avoir
des règles des contrôles mais de
s'étonner que nous puissions avoir y
compris pas loin de chez nous des normes
qui n'ont rien à voir avec des
fermusines qui compte 10 fois ou 100
fois le nombre de truille ou le nombre
de poulet qui serait autorisé sur notre
territoire
l'hypocrisie ne peut pas servir de base
à une écologie punitive si nous avons
des règles qui sont bonnes pour la
planète il faut les appliquer partout et
si à la fin en prenant des décisions en
France on met sous cloche une partie de
notre activité et que ça augmente les
importations ce sera bon ni pour
l'écologie ni pour l'économie ni pour la
planète c'est le défi de cohérence qui
nous attend remci monsieur le ministre
monsieur mollac
oui je vous rejoins monsieur le ministre
nous n'avons pas à exporter nos gaz à
effet de serre ou nos produits
phytosanitaires dans d'autres pays nous
devons produire chez nous ce dont nous
avons besoin pour nous nourrir cependant
j'attire votre attention sur le fait que
les agriculteurs qui sont sur les
barrages attendent des réponses précises
nettes et il ne va pas falloir tarder à
leur les donné parce que sinon nous
allons aboutir à une désespérance pour
ça que je vous interpelle là-dessus nous
avons besoin de choses concrètes le
discours du premier ministre hier n'a
pas suffit à calmer la colère donc je
j'en appelle à votre bon sens et à des
annonces rapide pour calmer la
désespérance je vous remercie mon cher
collègue la parole est à Monsieur
Francis Dubois pour le groupe des
[Musique]
Républicains
madame madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Premier Ministre notre ferme France
brûle et vous regardez ailleurs votre
gouvernement avec l'aide de l'Europe et
de son écologie normative prépare le
plus gros plan social jamais vu un plan
social imperceptible et sournois où les
agriculteurs disparaissent un à un au
cœur de nos territoires ruraux ce sont
pas les annonces faites vendredi avec
une botte de paille en guise de pupitre
ou les C petites minutes d'hier dans
votre discours de politique générale qui
suffiront à calmer la colère de nos
agriculteurs ces mises en scène sont
théâtrales mais absolument pas à la
hauteur du désarroi et des attentes de
nos paysans ils attendent des mesures
conjoncturelles immédiates des mesures
structurelles fortes pour permettre à
notre agriculture de rester championne
du monde grâce à sa productivité son
excellence et sa durabilité face à un
marché international dérégulé à un pacte
vert européen étouffant une économie
nationale surrégulée suradministrée par
une surtransposition écologiste à la
française il est primordial de faire de
notre agriculture une priorité de la
nation de la souveraineté alimentaire
une cause nationale c'est pour cela qu'à
l'initiative de mon collègue Julien div
nous avons présenté ce matin avec mes
collègues du groupe LR un livre blanc
comprenant des mesures pragmatiques
simples de bon sens émanant de toutes
nos rencontres de terrain dès
aujourd'hui prenez en compte ces
propositions une fois de plus ne mettez
pas sous le tapis comme vous l'avez fait
pour la loi revalorisant les retraites
agricoles sur les 25 meilleures années
que vous refusez de mettre en
application monsieur le Premier ministre
je vous exhorte à passer des paroles à
l'action prenez des mesures immédiates
sanctionner fortement et sans délai ceux
qui ne respectent pas les lois égalibes
sur la TR surtransposition à la
française laner dès aujourd'hui un
moratoire le temps d'évaluer l'utilité
de toutes ces normes stoppez toute
négociation des accords de libre échange
tant que vous n'avez pas réussi imposé à
l'Europe la mise en place des clauses
miroir vous espériez un état de grâce
vous voici en état de siège attendez la
colère des paysans sauvez notre
agriculture notre souveraineté
alimentaire il y a
urgence je vous remercie la parole est à
Madame priscat evno porte-parole du
gouvernement merci merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Député je pense
qu'il y a deux démarches et deux
attitudes ici la première consiste à
chercher des coupables en permanence et
une autre à trouver des solutions je
pense qu'ici dans cette belle
institution nous devons nous attacher à
trouver des solutions non ce n'est pas
la faute de l'Europe non ce n'est pas la
faute de ce gouvernement ni même des
anciens gouvernements qui avaient jadis
voté une certaine loi la loi LME qui
donnait les pleins pouvoirs à l'époque à
la grande distribution et ce que est
venu conforter effectivement et réparer
les lois égalime voté par cette majorité
je pense qu'aujourd'hui sur les
différents sujets que vous avez énoncé
que ce soit les clauses miroir les
négociation commerciale oui nous sommes
au travail nous sommes à la manœuvre le
Premier ministre a fait un certain
nombre d'annonces vendredi dernier il
était encore hier soir avanthier soir et
ce matin avec les représentants
syndicaux et nous continuerons à
travailler et sur cela et bien oui je
vous demande de nous rejoindre dans ce
travail dans cette volonté d'avancer
pour ces femmes pour ces qui travaillent
au quotidien pour prendre soin de leur
bêt et de leur territoire nous vous
attendons la porte est ouverte merci
beaucoup madame la ministre la séance
des questions gouvernement est terminée
la séance est
suspendue